hello welcome to ikea where our motto is
you get what you pay for and sometimes a
little less you may think the greatest
frustration you'll receive from heading
down to your local ikea warehouse is
spending a few hours walking around the
labyrinthian showroom or maybe arguing
with your partner in broken swedish
about the correct way to put together a
bjorksnos or perhaps even needing to
slide a piece of cardboard under the
front left corner of your pack's
wardrobe because otherwise it'll wobble
but these are nothing compared to you
getting trapped inside of scp-3008
also known as the infinite ikea not only
can you spend so long in this eternal
flat pack purgatory that your bones may
turn to dust on the show floor but the
murderous staff those are the malformed
faceless weirdos in ikea uniforms will
hunt you down and beat you to death for
not leaving and believe us leaving is a
whole lot harder than you'd like to
think that's why we put the question to
you how would you survive or even escape
scp-3008 the infinite ikea and these are
your best and most
interesting answers connor nolan said
with limitless refilling food and a vast
expanse of ikea toolkits and
construction materials the endless ikea
sounds like a pretty alright place to be
stuck all things considered we love your
positive attitude conor sometimes having
a nice outlook on life can make any
situation even being stranded in a
dimension full of affordable swedish
furniture just that little bit nicer
however if you want to survive you're
also going to need to be realistic
during the day yes the worse you'll have
to deal with is getting lost the risk of
not having food and the extensional
horror of knowing you may draw your last
breath inside an ikea but at night the
staff will actively hunt and try to kill
you and if you're not prepared believe
us they will so by all means keep your
optimism but don't allow that sunny
attitude to allow you to drop your guard
or the next set of meatballs might be
made out of you purple panda said i
would simply hide in one of the cabinets
in the kitchen aisle for the night then
come out during the day for food and
return back to my tiny lodge and then
rinse and repeat until i die of old age
and for extra protection i duct tape the
inside of the cabinet door at night it
wouldn't be much different from my
current life now that's a little more
like it it's not a bad idea to keep
things simple when you're trapped inside
scp-3008 and making a cabinet your home
is a good way to potentially avoid the
wrath of the staff however getting a
little bit of conor's more hopeful
mentality may also help after all why
resign yourself to dying inside the ikea
when you can keep the fires of hope
alive like the kind of flames produced
by a lovely cinlig scented candle
available at ikea for a dollar forty
nine dirt said dig a hole just dig a
giant tunnel system underground and put
rugs over the entrances have tunnels
going to sources of food water etc staff
won't find you if you cover your
entrances you might say however where do
we get digging tools the garden section
or just make them this would be a long
project so you would most likely have to
stay in a small base until you dig
enough this idea is certainly ambitious
your biggest problem is probably that
the only digging equipment available in
ikea is the grass model a 4.99 set of
three gardening tools including a tiny
hand shovel given that the actual layout
of the ikea appears unpredictable and
ever expanding it would also be
incredibly difficult to properly plan
and create tunnels even if you had
decades to do it though of course maybe
you're an expert tunneler and if that's
the case we apologize sincerely for
besmirching your honor lama fans said i
would make a wall of toilets and live
off of crayons we have good news and bad
news the good news is that ikea stocks
the mala 12-piece crayon set giving you
a delicious variety of colors to try
while trapped in the infinite ikea the
bad news is that these crayons have
pretty much no nutritional value so your
flushing fortress may actually become a
porcelain prison as your body and mind
slowly give out from a lack of
sustenance getting bludgeoned to death
by the staff inside of your toilet tower
would probably be a mercy in the end gw
said i would honestly stay if i got
stuck there with things like when day
breaks over the horizon build a home on
the steel supports overhead using a
pull-up ladder to get up and down and
live as comfortably as possible this is
certainly a valid point a number of
horrific xk class under the world
scenarios like
scp-001 the dreaded when daybreak's
event wouldn't actually affect the
inside of the infinite ikea seeing as
its lights function as a kind of
internal sun and if it's high enough
above sea level you wouldn't have to
worry much about climate change either
the staff trying to beat you to death
every night may put a damper on things
though sanik the hedgehog said i don't
think the staff are faster than the
speed of sound that's true sanic but
there are also no chili dogs inside of
the infinite ikea and that's no good kai
wilkie said when it comes to daytime i'd
search for other survivors that are
inside with me i would work with them to
build a civilization and live together
as it gets close to night i'd search for
food and supplies to keep us alive
through the night when it becomes
morning i'd clean up the bodies and
search for more survivors this is one of
the most tried-and-true methods of
long-term survival in the infinite ikea
however as you'll find with almost
everything in life it is easier said
than done even some of the largest
settlements inside 3008 have been
destroyed by careless decisions after
all your months and years of hard work
building up fortifications gathering
supplies creating a new form of
entertainment where you turn to vows
your son toilet brushes into puppets
that perform inside of a cardboard box
all of that effort can be lost in a
split second when one person forgets to
lock the carlby countertop fence and
staff members come flooding in hazel
said if they had a wifi connection and i
had my phone food and a shower i would
be 100 fine and maybe a tv good news
ikea has wi-fi and food bad news unless
you can by some act of pure luck find
the staff quarters there's unlikely to
be a shower in the building not a
working one at least the appliances in
the bathroom section are not operational
and frankly they should warn you of that
to avoid embarrassing situations but
enough about why we're banned from the
local ikea because there's more bad news
there are no tvs in ikea though you can
get yourself a classy and tasteful
brimnes tv stand and simply imagine that
the fake tv sitting on it is real or
there's always the devalgia sun toilet
brush puppets mob recon said i would
dress up as an ikea employee and when
the staff tried to attack me i just
claimed to work there we think your
heart is in the right place but
considering the staff within 3008 don't
look human at all you'd probably need to
go a little more extreme to convince
them that you're one of them like
grayson k grayson k said i remember from
one video about scp-3008 that the staff
are completely empty they have no organs
at all so what someone could do is just
wear the hollowed-out staff as a costume
to move among other staff at night see
that's dedicated to the performance true
frightening dedication seeing that the
staff aren't exactly crafty this could
actually work however if your disguise
is good enough to fool other members of
the staff then there's a good chance
that other survivors living in 3008
might think you're actually a member of
the staff running around at night and
you may end up taking avorta chef's
knife to the face 9.99 in the kitchen
section random user said as soon as
night comes i'd simply lock myself in
the nearest bathroom with some furniture
and cry then when the morning comes i'll
get my daily rations and the cycle
repeats not a bad idea we personally use
this method in our own lives every
single day and we're not even trapped in
the infinite ikea
moving on sam yates said i'd build some
sort of fortress out of big thick rugs
the staff could attack and break the
base made of wood but you could easily
punch your way through a rug i don't
know strangely there's been very little
research into that area sam perhaps rugs
are the ultimate recipe for fortress
structural integrity maybe all those
kings and queens and dukes and counts
were wrong and stone castles weren't the
answer it was rugs the whole time the
problem is if you're wrong and the staff
gets in it'll be the last mistake you
ever made as you die on a pile of
langstead and stage rum rugs pope
koolaid said i'd do what any middle
class american would do in that
situation get my gun sorry to tell you
holy father but they don't sell guns in
ikea unless you like taking your gun to
ikea with you all the time just in case
one of those shady overscad league
fridges tries something shrek's cousin
said easy just file a lawsuit saying
that one of the employees injured you
this might get you a pretty hefty cash
settlement from ikea if you ever escape
and the scp foundation doesn't get you
with amnestics first the staff
unfortunately seemed to have less
respect for the rule of law
moocow4you2 said talk about
scp-2521 and be instantly removed from
the storm this would be a method to
escape yes but we can't promise you'd
like where it takes you any more than
scp-3008
tiny sarv said i would tell the staff
that they should let me see their
manager for the poor customer service
and if i die so be it ah the little
known as cp 3008-3
also known as the karen the one entity
found within scp-3008 that is perhaps
even more terrifying than the staff you
can definitely try this technique but we
can't promise it will get the results
you want there doesn't seem to be an
entity above the staff that is
controlling them or even managing their
schedules and days off like demon dan's
unseen supervisor but if there was it
would likely be something even more
terrifying than the staff and you would
probably think that the staff is doing
an okay job and if you don't like it you
can take your business elsewhere dawawa
said i'd simply die hey we appreciate
your honesty at least but we think it's
generally better to hold on to hope try
your best to survive and perhaps even
escape this terrifying anomalous
situation after all you're only truly
out when you count yourself out p and q
cowboy channel said i would start to
worship the staff and even give them
sacrifices this is definitely a creative
solution but not one that we actually
think would solve anything after all the
staff aren't actually sentient beings
they seem to act on pure instinct
attacking any interlopers within the
store at night so no amount of
sacrifices will ever truly appease them
you're better off teaming up with other
humans and fighting for survival grace
said i'll eat the monsters they look
delicious
well thank you for sharing grace and as
for the rest of you if you ever find
yourself inside the infinite ikea and
you happen to see grace prowling the
showroom near you then perhaps keep your
distance especially if she looks hungry
if she's willing to eat the staff who
knows what else she's capable of
fortnite stuff said i would survive in a
weird way i would die then i would be
out while we suppose you would
technically be out of the infinite ikea
in a grim existential sense we think you
may have misunderstood the meaning of
survive there but don't worry you'll be
able to learn about all that and more
from our new sister channel words
explained okay i made that up sorry mr
mr derp said as someone who has been in
several ikeas never use the men's room
oh
god we're so sorry we can only imagine
the horrific things you've seen it'll
probably make 682 shudder in fear
kiruchan said i would build the
community inside and make myself the
leader make people fight and find food
on my behalf nothing is better than
being lazy and having people at your
command while all of the strange
communities within scp-3008 do require a
leader if you try to install yourself as
some kind of flat pack dictator chances
are you're going to get overthrown
during a revolution and exiled at which
point you'll probably be killed by the
staff the message be nice to people
kindness costs nothing after all and if
you're going to be trapped in an ikea
with a bunch of strangers for
potentially years on end you're going to
want them to actually like you toxic
dynamics said i would just watch the
infographic shows video you versus
scp-3008 and do what they say yes that
is an excellent video containing
everything you need to know about
surviving your time in scp-3008
i think we should all watch it and then
subscribe to the infographics show for
more great videos every day and of
course ring the bell to turn on
notifications that's the best idea we've
heard all day and there we have it folks
thanks to everyone for sending in their
thoughts and ideas if you want to be
involved in the next one keep an eye on
our community post for the next
opportunity for you to throw in your two
scp cents and in the meantime maybe do
your furniture shopping online now go
check out scp-3008 trapped in ikea and
scp-087 the stairwell for more scps
you'll really want to get out of